hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the 2018
batumi Chess Olympiad I was played
between brazilian grandmaster alexandra
Hilario Takeda dos Santos fear this is
not the first game we've seen by this
gentleman if you remember some 11 months
ago we we featured a nice game between
him and his girlfriend they met in a
chess tournament he's playing against
Andorian international master Robert
Solow Movida and it's really an
interesting game that features a very
exciting puzzle at the end of the game
so before we check out the game we do
have a couple of nice photos the
official photographer of the Batumi
chess olympiad is David Lada so all the
photos featured here will be will have
been taken by him but I will put a whole
lot of a lot of useful links in the
description below to the official Batumi
Chess Olympiad page at the their
official Flickr page where you can check
out all of the photos from every round
and you will there have who is the
photographer responsible for the photo
and the officials of the bottom it says
Olympia decided that you can use all the
photos in any way you like in you just
cannot sell them like for example as a
stock photos but you know you can use
them you will not be copyright
infringement or do let's check out some
nice photos by David Lara right there we
have a nice photo from the opening
ceremony there you have some officials
with Bhishma Vishwanathan Anand and the
nanotech Nitza then we have a very nice
photo there you can see all of the flags
of the countries participating in the
Olympiad naturally if it's really all of
the all the flags but I'm sure the
officials Mitch made sure that there
were here we have also from the crowd
there was a very nice program I didn't
still have haven't had the opportunity
to watch the opening ceremony but I've
seen some channels have uploaded some
footage like I've seen some footage and
shares based India's channel so you can
check it out if you want here also we
have you can really see that today
spent a lot to make this a very
memorable chess olympiad also here we
have a nice man on a horse because I
mean why not and also here we have a
very nice close-up of Nigel short so I
do hope you enjoyed that as well
but let's check out the dis game so
Alexandre opens the game with Knight to
f3 already opening we have d5c for the
Reta gambit and here Robert accepts the
RET again but he plays D captures on c4
and we have a knight to a three for the
moment an awkward square for the knight
but the night will definitely recapture
the pond and reposition itself it's a it
really makes no sense to try and defend
the c4 pawn with something like Bishop
to e6 because simply three and now there
is no way to defend at the pawn anymore
so after Knight 283 we have a six Knight
captures and now b5 kicking away the
night in the night to e3 and for the
moment it is a very weird square for the
knight yes but it is in the spirit of
the hyper modern theory and the reti
opening where you don't control at the
central which your pawns but rather with
your pieces for now the Knights but very
soon the the bishops will be
fianchettoed so okay Bishop the b7
we have g3 white also prefers to be in
care of his light square bishop the
knight to f6 Bishop to g2 and now II six
black prepares to develop the darks
worship and the castle to safety we have
castles by Alexander brush up to e7
and now b3 oxen under now prepares the
Finca to the dark square Bishop as well
we have castles Bishop to b2 and de now
c5 and here you can see if we're playing
the black pieces there is nothing you
know to feel bad about your light square
Bishop is an excellent piece countering
White's light square bishop here the
black Bishop is also very nice the
knight is ready to jump into the game
the Queen has a lot of squares via which
you can develop the Queen so black can
be very happy about himself and how this
opening is turning out for him Queen to
c2 developing the Queen and also
connecting rooks 9b d7 we
rook a to see one and now comes h6 rook
F to D one so all of whites pieces are
now developed and the rook to c8 black
wants to do the same Queen to be one a
very nice maneuver preparing queen bee
one queen two a one two really pressure
blacks King side here and the now point
a B six black wants to develop his
pieces as well Queen to a-1 explained
and now rook F to d8 countering both
Brooks h3 by white and not allowing this
g4 square for the Black Knight but also
preparing nice to G for himself to
perhaps open the open up the H file and
start some sort of a King side attack
Bishop to f8 now this night can move as
the bishop is now giving further
protection to the g7 pawn and we have d3
here and okay preventing ideas like c4
and white is simply improving the
position overall Bishop to c6 black
wants to do a similar idea like white it
did here on the Queen side he wants to
play Queen to b7 and also have a queen
Russia battery against white light/white
slide square bishop we have Knight to g4
this was planned Knight captures in g4 h
captures on g4 and Queen to b7 now a
black continues which is playing
normally here white pushes efore
preventing this idea and now this night
can move and here we have a 5 I better
move for black here would be f6 and
after f6 black keeps a better position
it's really an excellent move really
controls the knight on f3 eliminates
this 'if I've and g5 squares for the
White Knight also really counters this
nice Queen Bishop battery there's really
nothing to hit here and also it prevents
this g5 thrust by white but instead I
move like a 5 was played and it black
really feels like there's nothing going
on on the King side and okay white has
to do something g5 is played we have H
capture some g5 9th capture some g5 and
here black continues once again like
nothing is happening on the King side
black pushes a 4 we have Bishop to h3 a
very nice move and
here Alexander is already planning a
very vile idea what you want to do here
with black is simply capture on b3 and
after white captures go rook the rook to
e8 give this rook some more activity
force the Queen to move back and then
continue simply developing say for
example via Bishop to e7 but instead
after Bishop to h3 rook to e8 was played
and okay doesn't really really a weird
move probably guarding against some
ideas like Knight captures on e6f
captures Bishop captures with the check
and then perhaps King G 2 2 root 2 H 1
seems like a very very annoying idea for
white but ok rook to e8 the defending d6
pawn and dena comes King to g2 white
does make room for the rook to enter the
game a capture Sun b3 and here white
completely ignores black he doesn't
recapture automatically and b3 but
rather rook to h1 and here what is
already significantly better you do have
to try and play something probably
Knight to f6 bringing another defender
into the game would have been the best
thing to do but here c4 was played and
here c4 is actually a very a very bad
move it's a crucial blunder that
completely throws the game away so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the move that Alexander played or
or any move that will win you the game
here it's really a wonderful idea as
usual I will give it a couple of seconds
it's not all that easy to spot it so you
know if you're not too sure give it a
minute or perhaps even two for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are in you are a
true master of chess studies and for
those who just want to enjoy a show if
you found Bishop to a5 that is
definitely the correct idea but also the
move that was played in the game works
just as far just as well
Bishop captures on e6 here it doesn't
really matter if you capture with the f1
or with the rook capturing with the rook
is the best thing you can do but it
doesn't matter because every get every
move loses rook captures an e6 and here
you have the wonderful move the last
move that was played in the game here
Alexander simply played rook to h8 check
and it was in this position that
Andorian international master Robert
Solow model resigned the game why did he
resign well whatever he does it's a
forced checkmate in five so here the
only move King captures on h8 and okay
here comes rook to h1
this comes with check King to g8 and now
you sacrifice another rook all this so
you can finally bring the Queen into the
attack a very nice idea
King captures Queen to h1 King moves and
now Queen to h7 will be checkmate a very
beautiful pattern and although it's
something you will often see in some
puzzles or or or in chess diagrams but
very rarely will you see it in a game in
a chess Olympia between a grandmaster
and an international master and it
doesn't even matter if I have to look to
h1 check you block with the rook because
the bishop is spinning the pawn here
doesn't really matter white will simply
capture and after black moves simply
continue sacrificing team captures and
the idea is the same once again
Queen to h7 this will be checkmate a
really really beautiful idea but yeah
after this first rook to h8 Roberts
resigned and he didn't allow Alexander
fear to continue this this beautiful
sequence of moves but yeah
before I forget the first thing you will
see in the description below will be a
link to the official but to me chess
olympiad youtube channel so do check it
out you know probably a lot of very
interesting videos will appear there
every day one such will be the first
thing you will see in the description
below will be an interview with
alexandra hilarious takeda dos santos
sphere so feel free to check it out and
do congratulate him on this wonderful
accomplishment because as he says in the
interview he really didn't expect such a
wild finish from from such a boring
opening as he says so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it feel free
to use hashtag suggestion to suggest
some other games from the Batumi chess
olympiad
as there are some I have decided to
cover for myself but if you know of an
interesting game feel free to suggest it
I would like to thank Thomas Bollinger
Dan
violets better cook it's Alan Santos and
SATA Miyagi for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check - on my
previous videos you're think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with another interesting video
thank you all and I'll see you soon